[Music]
it's a Monday edition of PMT ot the last
Monday before PF t live returns and PF t
OT actually means PF t OT for now it's
PF t only because we don't have the
morning show but again it's just a week
away and when we return to PF t live we
will know whether or not cowboys running
back Ezekiel Elliott showed up for
Cowboys training camp the report day is
Thursday they gather in Dallas and then
they travel to Oxnard California and it
was just a week ago that I first caught
wind of the possibility that Ezekiel
Elliott won't show up for training camp
prior to that everyone thought that
number one he wasn't going to get a new
contract from the Cowboys this year
number two he was okay with that well he
may not get a new contract and he may
not be okay with it and since we
reported last Monday that he was
privately telling people that he's
thinking about holding out it has
snowball to a certain extent over the
weekend we reported that Elliott is
actually making plans to travel out of
the country in lieu of going to training
camp and now Ian Rapoport of the NFL
says that Elliott hasn't made a firm
decision about whether or not he's going
to hold out of course it's all
contingent on whether or not progress is
made toward a new contract so if the
Cowboys do nothing it looks like his EQ
Elliott is going to hold out if the
Cowboys give him a clear indication he's
going to get that contract or talks are
moving in that direction where they've
made an appropriate promise or whatever
the case may be
then he shows up so this is all very
tenuous right now and it appears that
the battle lines have been drawn without
an indication he's going to get that
financial reward entering year four of
his career
it looks like Ezekiel Elliott will not
be showing up for the start of the
Dallas Cowboys training camp another guy
who may or may not show up for the start
of training camp is a player entering
year four of his career of a four-year
contract member Zeke has five but Chris
Jones the Chiefs defensive end who plays
a lot of defensive tackle has a
four-year deal he was a second-round
pick back in 2016 and now the question
is will he continue
to stay away from anything in everything
related to preparation for the season he
skipped the voluntary offseason program
he skipped the mandatory minicamp I'm
told that no decisions have been made
about whether or not he's going to show
up for camp all options are being
considered it won't surprise me if he
holds out an important wrinkle to keep
in mind as it relates to Jones is that
August 6 deadline we spoke about that
deadline last week in relation to
Elliott and my point is it doesn't
matter to Ezekiel Elliott if he fails to
show up by August 6 and then in turn
fails to get a year of credit toward
free agency because he's more than a
year away from free agents he's got two
years left on his contract he'd be
making his stand to get paid and whether
or not he picks up a year of credit
toward free agency wouldn't matter to
him just like it didn't matter to Erin
Donald the last two years or didn't
matter to Darrelle Revis Chris Johnson
and others now for Chris Jones he's in
the last year of his contract he needs
that fourth year of service to be
eligible for free agency next year but
here's the thing to keep in mind if
Chris Jones doesn't show up by August 6
what that means is as long as he shows
up by the Tuesday after week 10 he gets
credit for the contract but he doesn't
have four years of service he would be
eligible not for unrestricted free
agency but for restricted free agency
and what the Chiefs could do at that
point is keep him with the relatively
low restricted free agency tender but
that would expose him to that
opportunity to sign an offer sheet with
another team and if the Chiefs don't
match the Chiefs would only get one
first-round draft pick as compensation
used to be the maximum tender for
restricted free agency was a first-round
pick and a third-round pick now the
maximum is just one first-round pick so
would the Chiefs take that chance even
though they could if Chris Jones doesn't
show up by August 6 would they use the
RFA tender next year my gut tells me
they probably wouldn't and they would
still use the franchise tag which can be
used for a restricted free agent so it'd
be in the same spot that he's going to
be and if he does show up by August 6 so
let's not put too much stock into August
6 as it relates to Jones or Elliott or
anyone else who may hold out because
ultimately this is about with hope
services to get that contract and the
best way to get a team's attention if
you're good enough to be viewed as a guy
that the team really needs is to stay
away until the team blinks and realizes
it's time to make the player a more
higher paid member of the organization
in Atlanta Julio Jones has shown up he
didn't hold out they've started training
camp but he's yet to get the new
contract that he says he was promised by
owner Arthur Blank and look once you
show up it's a lot harder to exert
leverage on the team now you can walk
out of camp but the consequences can
become very very dire if the team sends
a five-day letter and the team
ultimately decides to put you on the
reserve left squad list which shuts you
down for the whole year it is rare that
a guy shows up and then leaves I don't
rule that out with Julio Jones but
here's the more likely scenario and
someone who's very plugged in with the
way these things work told me this
earlier today because Julio Jones got a
new contract last year from the Falcons
on July 26 the Falcons are likely unable
to give Jones the kind of contract that
he wants now until the one-year
anniversary of that last deal it gets
very complicated convoluted beyond my
understanding of the way the rules work
but the case seems to be in there are
other people around the league who think
this that the jump that the Falcons and
Julio Jones have a deal in place and
it's just a matter of waiting for that
one-year anniversary of the last
contract to come and go before they do
the deal that has been done on a wink
nod basis behind the scenes to coax
Julio Jones to show up for training camp
of course whether or not there's any
merit to that we'll find out later this
week it's now the 22nd of July the 26th
is coming up on Friday if that new deal
is announced if it's signed
maybe we can can wonder even more
strongly whether or not that deal was in
place when he showed up at the start of
training camp when the Chiefs start
training camp receiver Tyreke kill will
be there we know that from Friday's
decision by the league to not suspend
him at all not to even discipline him in
any way for the various potential
violations of the personal conduct
policy but that's not the end of it as
it relates to Hills future with the
Chiefs
unrelated to whether or not he'll be
disciplined suspended whatever and again
for now the answer is he won't be with
that door open for the possibility of
additional evidence not available to the
NFL coming to light at some point down
the road but let's assume nothing ever
comes of it as it relates to Tyreke
Hills contract there's still a chance
that he won't be a member of the team
over the long term and here's why they
already started negotiating a deal that
happened before the off-field incident
kind of took center stage for the Chiefs
offseason program but before things
really hit full boil Jay Glazer of Fox
who also writes a weekly mailbag column
for the athletic he pointed out he had
heard some trade rumblings at the outset
of free agency about Tyreke kill now if
it's not related to what possibly was
coming down the pipeline for Tyreke kill
that means that it may have arisen from
the financial demands that were being
made on Hill's behalf and you can make
the argument the guy was worth 20
million dollars a year or more but when
you're the Chiefs and you have to pay
guys like Patrick mahomes and Chris
Jones and other great players who were
either on the team or will be on the
team in the future you have to make some
tough decisions and with me Cole Hardman
they're drafted in round two out of
Georgia and ostensibly at the time he
was picked the replacement for Tyree
kill in the short term maybe Hardman's
the long term replacement and Hardman
gives the Chiefs the opportunity to
really study what he can do and he's
drawn some favorable comparisons the
guys like Hill and Deshawn Jackson from
Chiefs coach Andy Reid if Hardman shows
the kind of flashes that we saw from
Tyreke kill his rookie year because
remember Hill didn't explode as a rookie
we saw some great things in special
teams but we didn't see him as that kind
of contributor he's been in 2017 and
2018 for the Chiefs offensively if we
see enough flashes from Hardman it
allows the Chiefs to move on from hill
after the season to do what they did
with Dee Ford last year tag Hill and
trade him and then let Hardman basically
take over the Tyreke Hill role if that's
what they choose to do and keep this in
mind
he'll may want 20 million a year
Hardman's under contract for four years
at a total of less than five million
dollars so look the biz
of football is going to be very relevant
for the Kansas City Chiefs because we
know Pat from Holmes is going to get his
and it's gonna be a record-setting deal
they have to be careful how much money
they they spend on other players on the
roster in order to have enough great
players around mahomes
and enough depth to deal with the
inevitable injury so it could be by the
time it's all said and done the Chiefs
decide to tag and trade Hill and make me
call Hardman the new Tyree kill in the
Kansas City Chiefs offense the New York
Giants had the move of the offseason
with the stunning but not really all
that shocking trade of Odell Beckham jr.
to the Cleveland Browns and Odell
Beckham in a lengthy interview with GQ
makes it clear that he wanted out of New
York we already knew that but he also
says he felt disrespected when the trade
rent down and and and I can understand
that okay he wanted out but he didn't
like the fact they didn't get a phone
call ahead of time and he really didn't
have any say and where he was going to
be traded you look what happened the
Antonio Brown he basically was able to
veto a possible trade to the bills hand
pick a trade to the Raiders get a raise
along the way and it could be that
Beckham feels miffed that he wasn't
included more in the process but the
bottom line is he wanted out and he got
out and that's what Beckham should be
focusing on and look there's gonna be so
much time spent in the coming weeks and
months focusing on what the Giants are
without Beckham and what Beckham is
without the Giants and whether or not
Beckham should have wanted out we're not
the Giants should have kept him I think
everybody involved will be best served
by just moving on and and I don't know
why Beckham continues to talk about the
Giants and III I feel like Beckham on
one hand doesn't like it when everybody
focuses on him and talks about him but
then on the other hand he doesn't
realize that by doing lengthy interviews
with publications like GQ he gives
people more things to talk about at some
point he'll understand the connection
between the things he says and does and
the reaction that those things generate
and he's always embraced that kind of
Fame and notoriety throughout his career
and here we are he's in season number
six now he doesn't quite seem to realize
the connection between the attention
that he attracts that he seems to covet
and the negative aspect of getting that
kind of attention the criticism that
goes along with it you just can't have
it both ways you can't have that hey
everybody look at me personality and
then get offended when people look and
don't like what they see or hear you may
be liking what you see in here coming
out of the other New York team this
season the Jets could be a lot better
their quarterback Sam Donald entering
year two of his career says the Jets are
in line to win a lot more games this
year now relative to what they did last
year that may not be enough to get to
the postseason but I've been a firm
believer between the Jets and the bills
one of those two teams is gonna rise up
and potentially contend for a wild-card
berth and maybe just maybe disrupt the
Patriots stranglehold on the ASEA stole
oh I don't believe that's gonna happen
what I think will happen is either the
Jets where the bills will get in that
neighborhood of seven eight nine games
and maybe in mid-december be in position
where if they get hot down the stretch
they could steal the six seed or the
five seed in the AFC it's not going to
be easy to do and I think that the real
question is who from the Jets bills and
dolphins is going to get the quarterback
position
in the right hands so that when Tom
Brady retires if he ever retires one of
those other three teams is really going
to be able to make a run at the New
England Patriots and I think this is the
year that we start to see which of those
three teams may be ready to eventually
challenge the Patriots whenever that may
be
and that's what's fascinating at some
point in the next two three four years
maybe not quite that long we're going to
see Bill Belichick with a new
quarterback taking on one of these other
quarterbacks and chances are one of
these guys whether it's darn old with
the Jets
Josh Allen with the bills or Josh Rosen
with the Dolphins or whoever the
Dolphins may get after this season one
of those guys can become a franchise
quarterback and they're not going to be
easy for the Patriots to beat especially
if the Patriots don't have Tom Brady all
right one last topic for today's pft ot
and this is something we've been talking
about throughout the offseason because
Chicago Bears continue to have a clown
show at kicker all due respect sorry but
it's true and the revolving door may
continue to spin and I've mentioned
before on the PFT p.m. podcast you have
to look at the way the offseason
continues to unfold and once we get to
training camp in the preseason there are
kicking competitions in other cities and
nobody's gonna carry more than one
kicker
well eventually somebody's going to cut
a kicker and the Bears are going to say
this could be our guy and here's the
problem for the Bears and this is one of
the downsides of being the team that
plays in the first game of the regular
season on September 5 the rosters don't
have to cut from 90 to 53 until August
30 and every team out there that has a
kicking competition may be inclined to
hold on to that other kicker as long as
possible because there's a chance the
Bears are gonna call and say hey if you
know which guy you're keeping maybe
we'll give you a conditional seventh or
sixth round pick for the other guy and
if ultimately all those other teams with
kicking competitions hold their guys
until August 30 they're in a whole lot
of time for the Bears to
bring guys in figure out who the winner
is
get that guy ready to go for a season
opening game on NBC with a ton of
pressure and it's gonna be a neverending
story I mean the Bears have everything
else taken care of other than the fact
that Vic Fangio left and has been
replaced by Chuck Pagano as defensive
coordinator there's really no other big
story with the Bears the big story is
who the hell is the kicker gonna be and
whoever that kicker is week one Thursday
night had better be ready to withstand a
ton of scrutiny because he's gonna feel
all of it on his shoulders when it's
time to kick and it could be the guy who
kicks for the Bears this year his guy
doesn't even know he's gonna join the
Bears until Monday or Tuesday before
that Thursday night game either way it
is gonna be a challenge an extra
challenge over and above the pressure
that a kicker already feels to be the
kicker for the Chicago Bears in 2019
that's it for this Monday edition of pft
ot a little programming note we will
have editions of PFT ot Tuesday Thursday
Friday this week other video content at
Pro Football Talk com episodes of PFT
p.m. and it's all leading up to the
triumphant or otherwise return of PFT
live next Monday morning Sims will be
back if he can be located I will be back
as long as I don't stray too far
from headquarters and we'll be off and
running getting you ready for the
arrival of the 2019 football season have
a great day and we'll see you back here
again the more
[Music]
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports